Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
you guys have been through such a
fascinating change in music too,
because I mean obviously lars was a huge
figure in the controversy surrounding
mp3s and that was during the napster
days.
That was the time where everybody
realized like,
Holy Shit,
something just happened,
you know,
and I don't think we realized it back
then.
I think lars in a lot of ways was one of
the first people sounding the horn.
He was one of the first people going,
hey,
all this selling records,
shit is gonna go away.
Like,
do you understand what's going on here?
People just taking things and putting
them online and this was a totally new
thing.
Absolutely.
And that poor guy still,
you know,
he's taking bullets,
he's taking hits for it.
Still tell really where,
oh everyone who's got a beef with any
other thing than uh,
you know,
napster,
they,
it just gravitates towards that all the
time.
That poor guy.
Yeah,
he got beat up by that and we all stood
behind him.
Obviously.
He was the spokesman for it.
He,
he,
he chose,
he chose to do that.
Management said,
hey,
this is coming,
this is coming.
Let's be the ones that stand up for
artists.
And he took that,
he,
he grabbed the flag and said,
I'm going.
And there were lots of other musicians
and people that were on board as well,
but they weren't as vocal or taking the
hits like he did.
There was something about,
you know,
even like a doctor Dre,
he was on board with it.
But for some reason in the rap world
it's like,
well,
it's all about money anyway,
so,
so what,
you know,
for heavy metal,
there was some kind of stigma around,
you know,
you,
you're,
you're an asshole if you're rich or if
you've been successful or something.
It's like we got to pull you down into
hell with us.
You know,
don't,
don't be getting good now.
You know?
Yeah.
So that was that stigma.
But there were other artists that would
show up at shows saying,
hey man,
I'm really glad you're doing what you're
doing.
It's like,
come on,
you know,
join us.
Oh No,
I can't.
my career would be over.
It's like,
you fuck,
you know,
it's so frustrating.
It's like,
dude,
do you believe in it?
Yeah.
Then stand up like,
yeah,
but no,
it will fall apart.
Something will happen.
My fans,
blah,
blah.
So they,
they were concerned about their own
careers and not the big picture of
artists.
And obviously these days you can see
there's no copyright laws.
There's no nothing,
man,
you can rip this and that and whatever
and do whatever you want with it.
There's a beauty to that and a lot of
creativity comes out of it,
but it gets watered down.
It gets,
you know,
I dunno,
we,
we acknowledge that.
Yeah,
there's inspiration somewhere for
everything.
But blatantly taking that and using it
is,
it's pretty frustrating to me.
Um,
and we're,
we're,
we were at that point where we were,
we had a such a following.
We had such a strength in Metallica that
we survived all of that stuff.
Um,
but there was a lot of bands that
didn't,
you know,
uh,
they couldn't sustain themselves,
couldn't feed their families because of
what happened.
And I think the frustrating part was no
one really understood that music is our
life.
You know,
if you take that,
if you take hours like the way we wanted
to present our music is part of the art.
Well again,
in an album,
meaning like one song leads to the next
song weaning,
well like releasing an album,
here's how we'd like to release it.
We don't want it leaked over here.
We don't want this happening.
We don't,
you know,
uh,
present a presentation is part of the
yard.
Like when you walk into an art studio,
the artist has been in there putting it
together.
Like,
okay,
I want you to see this first.
And then that,
and then you go here and you get Bam.
You know that there's a passion behind
that.
And when someone just throws it out
there,
then it kind of loses a leaves as an
impact.
Um,
so if I'm complaining,
punched me in the face,
but we have survived and we feel good
about it and we've adapted.
But the record companies certainly did
not,
you know,
they took it
a hard hit.
But also,
you know,
when you look at the record deals,
the deals that record companies make
with artists,
and you see like what a record company
selling.
Well,
they're only selling your work without
your work,
without your creativity,
without your creations.
There's nothing to sell.
That's all they sell.
But then you look at these insane
insanely one side and deals that they
cut with artists,
especially emerging artists,
they might be a little bit more
desperate,
don't realize the potential,
especially the potential for income that
they might have in the future.
I mean,
I've seen some of those,
I don't know,
there was that one that somebody said
that courtney love didn't really write
it,
that it was ghost written.
I Dunno who the fuck wrote it,
but Courtney love put it out saying that
she wrote it.
But it was a breakdown of how artists
make money from the creation of an art
creation of an album to having it sold
in record stores to where the money gets
extracted and how much is left for the
actual artists.
It's pretty fucking disturbing.
Yeah.
Even,
uh,
well yeah.
A couple of years ago,
we,
we got the rights to our catalog,
our,
our music from kill 'em all up till now.
We own it finally,
which is weird.
I tell my kids,
Hey,
you know,
let's go celebrate.
We've got,
we got the master recordings,
we own it finally.
And they were just looking at me like,
what the hell are you talking?
You wrote it,
why isn't it yours?
Right.
Okay.
Well I had a little talk about how it
was back then.
You know,
you would somewhat sell a little bit of
your soul to get a bigger something.
You know,
it was basically the record company was
a bank and a marketing tool to get you
where you want it to be.
So,
uh,
you know,
it was a necessary thing at that time,
but it's great to have our stuff back
and be able to,
you know,
we own our own record press.
How cool is that?
Whoa.
In Germany,
uh,
one of our management people found a
place that had some machines that were
for sale and we bought one.
And so we press our own vinyl man.
Wow.
And we could kind of do whatever we
want.
What color vinyl today,
you know,
or what crazy things you can do.
You know,
uh,
you guys can kind of do whatever the
fuck you want now,
right?
Much.
You don't need a record company do
anything.
Well,
it depends.
Uh,
we have a record company.
We own our own in America or North
America.
The rest of the world's a little
tougher.
You know,
there's a lot of countries out there,
especially in Europe and there's no way
we can deal with the distribution in
each different countries.
So we've cut really good deals with,
with other record companies that have a
vision and a,
have a love for Metallica and understand
that this is powerful stuff and people
love it and we want to be part of the
family.
Um,
but having your own record press is a
pretty darn cool thing.
There was really inspired by Jack White,
uh,
who,
you know,
white stripes,
fame,
you know,
rec on tears.
He's done a lot of stuff,
but he,
he loves that stuff.
He's pressing his own stuff.
He's coming up with different ways of
doing vinyls and colors and hidden
tracks and cool stuff like that.
And it's,
it's just another way to get creative
in,
in your career is vinyl.
What's selling more than anything now
when it comes to actual physical hard
copies of things,
I don't know the numbers and they're
probably very all over the place,
but vinyl has never gone away.
And it's,
it's,
I dunno if it's coming back,
but it's more popular than it was.
I think there's just something tactile
about it.
There's something great that people are
finally understanding that you can look
at artwork,
you can feel it.
And then the,
the,
the ritualization of opening up the
player,
taking it out and blowing on it,
clean and it,
putting it down,
setting the needle down.
And it's,
that's something really cool.
I just,
I came down to La a few months ago and
hung out with some high school buddies.
It's like,
Hey,
what do you want to do?
I was listening to some songs and he
takes out the Kansas,
you know,
album puts it on.
And
I was like,
dude,
this sound
so great.
Wow.
And we were actually listening to music,
sitting down and listening to it.
My kids got into vinyl,
they got a,
you know,
like at urban outfitter you buy the
little,
the setup now and that's where they,
that's where you can get vinyl.
It's,
it's there,
there are some record stores out there,
but that's where they gravitate towards.
Got I'm this little player and uh,
they just picked out some album covers,
date,
even know who they were.
It's like this cow,
this cover looks cool,
this speaks to me.
I'm buying this.
I remember doing that kind of thing.
Cool.
Cover.
Yup.
That's how I discovered tons of bands.
So they go into the room and you know,
I leave him alone for a while and then
come back and I haven't come out.
It's like,
what's going on?
I look in there,
there,
you know,
the record players on the floor is
covers and stuff strewn out all over the
place and they're laying on the floor
listening to,
it's like,
that is what that was me,
you know?
Uh,
and my,
my daughter comes out,
she said,
dad,
you'll never guess what,
what their song
on the other side.
Like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
It's not a CD.
You know,
I was like,
she just covered some huge thing,
you know.
Wow.
Well that was one of the things that was
not,
what is this vinyl sales outperform
digital downloads for the first time.
Oh Wow.
Shows a significant shift in how people
are consuming music.
That's really interesting.
Stigma.
I tell you.
That's just cool.
Uh,
uh,
in general,
the more ways you can get music to
people,
the better.
Well,
I think the other thing that you were
saying,
it's,
it's like,
it's a whole presentation.
The album cover,
you open it up,
the inside,
the artwork,
all that represents your vision of what
you guys are trying to put out.
And that was one of the things that kind
of went away with digital.
Like all of a sudden there were no album
covers or the CD,
he was that big.
So you couldn't really,
there wasn't,
you know,
it's like a tiny little piece of art and
if you're downloading it,
you're not even getting that.
You're just,
you're just getting the music itself.
That's it.
Well,
Eh,
you,
you would get,
you know,
downloadable artwork,
but you're not really looking at the
artwork while you're listening to it on
your mobile device.
Right.
You know,
so,
you know,
the event of sitting down and,
and disappearing into the music,
you know,
being a real music listener,
not,
I mean,
while you're driving,
I get it.
It's,
it's keeping you from killing people on
the road,
but when you go home and you sit and you
just get lost in stuff,
even,
um,
like those cheap frigging headphones,
man,
the little ear buds,
my kids were listening to stuff on that.
It's like,
you guys haven't experienced music,
like,
good sound here.
Try these headphones on.
They're like,
whoa.
I hear stuff I didn't hear before.
And uh,
but just seeing my kids get excited
about going to a live concert,
you know,
they there and they absorb it in like
every sense.
You're not just having your ears hear
something and that will never be,
I dunno,
maybe the frigging goggles or some kind
of a audio visual stuff will reproduce
live shows,
but there's something about being next
to a sweaty fucker at a Gig and you
know,
them pushing you or uh,
you know,
seeing someone headbang wildly are
getting thrown over the top of you and
there's just so much smells,
things like that.
It just can't be recreated.
So live music.
My daughter,
just like,
I can't believe that guy just pressed a
button on his computer and he's singing
over his own music that's not
performing.
You know,
she discovered that on her own.
Hey,
these guys are actually playing their
instruments and they fucked up.
They fucked up a song.
It was so cool.
You know,
I saw something that I wouldn't have,
you know,
really cool like that.
Yeah.
The lip sinking thing,
man,
that when you go to see a concert and
you find out that people are lip
sanking,
that's so disturbing.
It's just what,
what have you done?
This is,
what is the point of this that is
disappointing.
What does live performance?
Live performance is supposed to be your
experiences thing actually happening.
You're watching this person expressed
themselves,
then they're not,
they're not pretending.
You're not supposed to be pretending.
Right.
Are you pretending you're you your money
back?
Cause you're not.
That's not,
that's not,
that's pretending.
That's not singing.
I've gone to see plenty of shows with my
kids and you can tell it's like,
all right,
it's the Mike's way over here and
they're still sing in.
And it's like,
well they have to have the backing
tracks cut.
They're,
they're dancing and they're out of
breath.
Like,
well fucking stop dancing and this song,
I mean,
are you a dancer or you're a musician or
a singer or whatever.
Can Cardio,
start running hills?
It can be done.
I go to Vail and run up the 14 are
exactly it.
It can be done,
but I've seen shows where there's that
going on and then he'll get real,
you know,
like sit down on a couch,
plug it in acoustic and,
and sing out of key and like really try
and struggle with the song or sing it.
You know,
it's like,
that's natural.
That feels good.
Who would not gravitate towards that
than listening to the album?
I got to listen to yell at my home.
Yeah.
That's why it's cool to just see an
acoustic set sometimes from people you
know,
just like it's as minimal as possible.
You're breaking it down to the bare
bones,
just a guitar and two people singing or
something,
you know?
Yeah.
That is pretty intimidating.
I tell you,
when we do like that Neil young benefit
where it's,
you know,
acoustic only,
and if you're your frigging neck naked
up there,
dude,
you know?
And every note is like,
you know,
and every fuck up on the vocal,
it's,
it's great.
I mean,
it's like when,
uh,
you know,
you go or you're going to be on a TV
thing and they put makeup on you.
It's like,
why are you doing that?
You know?
Exactly.
Uh,
so when people see me in person,
they think,
damn,
you're one ugly fuck.
It's like,
no,
I want to be as ugly as possible to
everyone.
So when they see me
go,
hey,
it's you,
you know?
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
You're not airbrushed.
You see a photoshop yourself and it's
like,
you know,
they smoothed out all your lines and
you're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Sometimes
sometimes you got to do it or like,
you know,
if you're in a band like I am and the
three guys get the stuff put on and then
I show up,
dude,
oh my God,
you're a shiny.
Exactly.
It's like people gotta go,
bye.
Fuck this band I do sweating.
Yeah,
right,
right.
When it comes to the napster thing and
with what happened with Lars,
I feel like there's two different
things.
There's something,
there's what's really happening and this
is how people look at it and what's
really happening was like all of a
sudden this door got opened up or this
Pandora's box got open.
Right,
and you guys were looking at it going,
well,
this is a,
we're going to lose our record sales.
Like,
do you understand that?
Like people have been consuming music in
a certain way.
You've been paying for music and that
paying for music is supported.
All these people that are a part of this
industry that makes albums.
There's this gigantic thing behind it.
This is all going to go away because you
just put a hole in the bottom of it and
all the money's going to get dropped
out.
But then the way it looks is Luca,
this rich motherfucker,
you know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't appreciate his fans.
Hey Man,
I can't afford your album right now.
Is it okay if I just download it for
free?
And a lot of people thought,
well,
hey,
people who can afford it will still be
downloading it and then they'll buy it
when they can.
But that wasn't really the case was it?
Nah,
I don't know.
I,
you know,
I'm all for convenience in the
technology moving forward.
Getting music out to people is the
important part,
but just make sure the artist gets what
they deserve from it because without
that,
it's going to become a hobby.
No one wants,
you know,
I don't want to see the paramedics show
up at my house and it's like a hobby for
him.
Hey,
you know,
I'm not really getting paid for what I
think I should get paid for my creation,
but I guess I'll save your life.
You know,
maybe,
uh,
people didn't relate that to their,
their career or something,
uh,
equivalent.
Well,
I think because the money wasn't
equivalent,
they looked at you guys like,
you guys are already so rich.
What do you give a shit?
There's no way you're going to be broke.
You guys made millions and millions and
millions of dollars a tour all over the
world.
And it became,
the touring thing was way artists made
money then.
Right?
Touring and merchandise and that's now
record companies are stressed.
Structuring their deals,
you know,
hey,
we get a piece of it.
Merch and touring.
See that's bizarre though.
The record companies getting a piece of
your touring to me is very strange and
I've seen not just a piece,
but an exorbitant amount and that
disturbs me.
Well that's the only way they can
survive.
No,
they shouldn't be around them because
then you become a parasite because you
don't deserve it.
I mean,
especially now where bands can literally
become gigantic because at Youtube we
didn't,
Justin bieber become huge just entirely
because of youtube.
Jamie knows,
look at him,
it's a fucking Justin Bieber fan.
He hides it.
Hey,
me too.
First I heard him saying,
I thought it was a girl.
I didn't even know it was a,
I didn't know.
Well,
I'll tell you the,
the whole,
uh,
you know,
would you,
would you go up to the artist and take
that out of his pocket?
You know,
would you go into a record store and
just lift that,
steal it right out the door with it,
you know,
what'd you do that with?
You know,
okay,
there's,
you know,
there's big corporations that are rich
and would you go walk in and just steal
their stuff?
I mean,
there's software companies that are
massive.
Would you go in there and just rip their
stuff?
I don't get that mentality.
I don't call me old school,
but you need to earn what you get and if
it gets stolen from you,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's hard to fathom.
And what it seems like to me,
and I,
I could be talking about my ass,
but the record companies dropped the
ball and the new record companies became
itunes control at all.
Here's how much we're charging for your
music and here's how much you're going
to get.
Everyone's even,
it's like some communist approach,
you know,
and I,
I don't understand.
I don't understand that.
If we're an artist and we make a lot of
money,
that's up to us.
If we give all our money away to charity
or we throw it back into a movie,
that bombs,
which happened,
um,
that's our choice.
We're the fucking artist.
We get to do what we want.
It's our party.
You're invited and we can destroy this
thing if we want.
I don't want you to destroy it.
Yeah.
The itunes distribution models a very
bizarre one.
It's very strange how they've,
they don't know what they're doing.
No one knows what they're doing.
And you know,
there was a system that worked and I'm
up for bucking the system and making it
better,
but it didn't,
it didn't get better.
It's like the,
like you said,
the cat got out of the bag and you can't
put it back in,
man.
You just can't.
Um,
so what do you do?
Well,
you got spotify or you got something
else where streaming's going to help get
the artists their money.
And it's,
it's,
um,
you know,
companies like that are losing money a
lot.
And spotify,
I don't,
I don't know the exact workings and I'm
not going to speak for them at all,
but it's hasn't been figured out yet,
is what I'm saying.
It hasn't been figured out how to make a
music model work.
And there's no one way,
maybe there will never be one way again,
and that's fine,
but it's still unbalanced.
Okay.
[inaudible].